je pense qu'il faut rétablir des règles
de la concurrence et quand il ya une
concurrence faussée et qui n'est pas
libre et la concurrence est faussée
notamment par encore une fois sur des
normes sociales environnementales et
fiscales donc il faut rétablir des
règles alors ensuite je suis pas je
n'aime pas beaucoup les taxes non plus
d'une façon générale mais simplement on
ne peut pas accepter effectivement le
dumping
quel que soit le dumping donc il faut
rétablir et au niveau européen je pense
que c'est la bonne
c'est la bonne dimension alors ensuite
il y aura avec les américains peut y
avoir des bras de fer moi je trouve
inadmissible qui effectivement des
américains s'arroge le pouvoir de
l'extraterritorialité leurs droits et il
faut trouver les moyens de riposter à
7,1 période américain par rapport aux
chinois effectivement le comportement
des chinois leur arrogance leur
agressivité
depuis quelques temps n'est pas
acceptable donc il faut avoir les moyens
effectivement de pouvoir faire
éventuellement des bras de fer avec eux
dire qu'on n'est pas dans un monde de
bisounours
on est dans un monde de rapports de
force et les rapports de force il faut
les établir
au niveau des continents alors ce qu'on
peut regretter c'est qu'au niveau
européen il n'y ait pas effectivement
une telle prise de conscience et que
depuis toujours
la france est la seule en fait avoir
milité pour une europe puissance et pour
une indépendance européenne alors qu'un
certain nombre de nos partenaires
européens eux se sont coulés dans le
moule effectivement d'un libre
échangisme absolue et totale y compris à
l'intérieur de l'europe avec tous les
dégâts de sa cause
à
[Musique]